MANDAR JOG: Hi,
my name is Mandar,
and I lead the extensibility
team for Istio at Google.
We recently gave a talk about
adding fine-grained mesh
telemetry to the service mesh.
When we moved from a monolith
to a microservices world,
we replaced an
in-memory function call
with the Remote RPC.
That essentially
replaced something
that was fast, reliable,
and secure with something
that was not as fast, not as
reliable, and not as secure.
Service mesh tries to
impart these qualities back
into the microservices world.
Istio uses Envoy as the
basis of its service mesh.
And Envoy has some fairly
good stats collection already.
However, one part that it
lacks is peer awareness.
Knowing [INAUDIBLE]
is extremely important
when you're talking
about microservices.
As part of this work, we
have added metadata exchange
as a standard part of HTTP flow.
Luckily, every pair of
communicating proxies
know who they are talking with.
We have also added
WebAssembly support to Envoy
as part of this
effort, which is going
to help the entire community.
All this work is available.
And it's still 1.4,
so you can try it out.
And the underpinnings are
available in the Envoy/WASM
repository in the Envoy org.
Please come by our
booth at Google,
and thanks for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]